.
- Comment elle est reçue,
cette pub-là, auus?
- Bien, c'est sûr qu'on est
un peu perplexes.
- Pierson Vaval est intervenant
taire auprès de jeunes
de Rivière-des-Prairies,
à Montréal. Il a l'impression
que ces publicités entretiennent
des stéréotypes.
PIERSON VAVAL, intervenant
communautaire, Équipe RDP
- C'est louche, des jeunes noirs
dans un parc au coucher
du soleil? Oui, c'est normal qut
des Québécois.
- C'est pas le concept
pour lequel je m'étais engagé
lorsqu'on m'a approché
pour réaliser cette pub.
- Selon le réalisateur,
le gouvernement a décidé
d'ajouter le mot "québécois"
sans son accord et lui deman
maintenant de retirer
la publicité.
KHOA LÊ, réalisateur
- C'est devenu une campagne
politique pour moivenu
une campagne nationaliste.
C'est devenu une campagne
d'intégration plutôt qu'une
campagne de sensibilisation.
- On appelle ça
des amis québécois.
- C'est pas vraiment le genre
de trucs qui m'accroche.
- Je suis les décisions que
la CAQ prend en gouvernant au
provincial et je trouve que
c'est pas tout à fait en accord
avec ce qu'ils essaient
de dire dans ces aà.
- Je pense qu'il y a comme
un effort, mais c'est peut-être
un effort maladroit.
- Le malaise est tel quedes humt
- Le malaise est tel que
des humoristes en ont fait
des paro
- On veut montrer aux Québécois
que vous êtes comme nous autres.
- Non, non, mais moi,
je suis Québécoise, là.
- Oui, osûr que vous
êtes Québécoise, mais on veut
dire les vrais Québécois, là.
EMNA ACHOUR, humoriste
- Je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
se sont sentis beaucoup
mieux représentés par nos
parodies que par les vraies
publicités parce qu'au moins
nous, on parlait des vraisenjeu.
- De voir qu'il y a une volonté
er de cet enjeu-
là, c'est une bonne chose, mais
en même temps, quand tu parles
de quelque chose comme ça,
ça t'engage comme gouvernement.
MARTINE ST-VICTOR, stratège en
comm. et dg, Edelman Montréal
- Quand on en arri
à la parodie comme ça, il faut
retirer ces publicités
et puis en retirant
ces publicités-là,
ça enverssage.
- Le ministre responsable
de la Lutte contre le racisme,
Benoit Charette, ne semble pas
avoir l'intention
Dans un courriel, son bureau
répète que la volonté
est de combattre les préjugés
envers les minorités visiblesoie
cet objectif.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Mon